going now from Georgia to Arizona
Kerry Lake who lost she lost nothing
happened other than Kerry Lake lost her
opponent Katie Hobbs got more votes in
the Arizona gubernatorial election on
November 8th Kerry Lake was recently at
Trump's house in Mar-A-Lago and now all
of a sudden she says she's going to try
to overturn the election results you
know we I don't know that I can say that
we were joking around but we certainly
talked about how it seems very clear
that the new strategy and it's not even
really a strategy because it hasn't
worked at all it's it's more of like a
last-ditch effort tactic the new thing
we're going to see from these
Republicans is when they lose they will
say that it's rigged and then they will
try to overturn the election and they
will continue putting out these
imaginary Milestones oh well we're
getting very close to submitting
affidavits all right I mean affidavits
aren't evidence strictly speaking they
can be considered but affidavits are not
evidence of wrongdoing well very soon a
court is going to hear our case Mike
pillow has been talking about that for
two years we're moving for
decertification we heard that one from
Steve Bannon many times is there such a
process as decertification no but we're
moving towards decertification and by
the way keep donating keep donating to
me donate to Trump donate to everybody
okay so here's a clip of Carrie Lake
Carrie Lake lost she had this pompous
arrogance going into the election I will
be the next governor of Arizona more
people voted for her opponent
when things go right the person who gets
more votes wins Kerry Lake doesn't like
that it looked like she was getting
ready to move on now she says she's
assembling evidence and she's going to
run some kind of campaign to overturn
the election Sarah to remedy this
assault on our democracy
this isn't about Republicans Or
democrats this is about our sacred right
to vote yeah what's funny is as much as
they claim it's not about Republicans Or
democrats they only claim that this
fraudulent stuff took place when a
Democrat has defeated a Republican
that so so find me a case where you try
to overturn an election in which a
republican defeated a Democrat find me
one example
a right that many voters were sadly
deprived of on November 8th
tens of thousands of you have reached
out pleading with me to fight this fight
is that even true tens of thousands I'm
sure thousands but tens of thousands
reached out just assured I will because
if we give up now we will no longer have
a country
attorneys are working diligently to
gather information sure whistleblowers
are coming forward and the curtain is
being lifted
whether done accidentally or
intentionally it is clear that this
election was a debacle that destroyed
any trust in our elections what she
means is I lost arizonans who choose to
make their voice heard on Election Day
should not be disenfranchised or
punished for choosing to vote in person
now what she's referring to is that for
a little while a few tabulators in
Maricopa County didn't work
that that's what she's talking about
yet they were
I want you to know Arizona I will
continue fighting until we restore
confidence and faith in our elections
you know I'm pretty confident and and I
have faith in what happened the
candidate who got more votes Katie Hobbs
is going to be the next governor of
Arizona and all of the evidence points
to the voters of Arizona wanted Katie
Hobbs to be the governor they can
recount it over and over they can do
these Audits and remember
they call for an audit the audit is done
and then they go no that was the wrong
type of audit they only looked
at a recount of the ballots without
evaluating whether the ballots were
valid the ballots were valid
it's the wrong type of audit well you
know they didn't look at whether there
were barbecue saw stains from a type of
barbecue sauce common in Missouri you
shouldn't have Missouri barbecue sauce
on Arizona ballots it just doesn't make
sense clearly there was some kind of
fraud what about bamboo fibers what
about uh pictures of koala bears tucked
into the ballots it's all varies you
will never satisfy them
that the process has been completed the
way they want and Luke Beasley our
correspondent who was recently at a
trump Rally For Us in uh
I believe he went to the Pennsylvania
one if they blend together I believe he
was in Latrobe Pennsylvania
Luke or was it North Carolina doesn't
matter Luke interviewed folks where they
said oh there was all this fraud and
Luke said yeah but there's no actual
evidence and they did the audit they go
no no no no that wasn't really an audit
in the way we wanted and what they mean
is it wasn't an audit that overturned
the election so that the Republican won
it's so completely predictable
thankfully it's over I mean it Katie
Hobbs won
she will be the governor nothing's
getting overturned period and the
problem now becomes this is standard
operating procedure for Republicans they
have now adopted this we don't like the
results we say it was rigged we say it's
just not believable that Katie Hobbs won
because she has fewer Facebook followers
it's similar to it's not believable
Biden won because his live streams
didn't get a lot of viewers or his
rallies didn't have huge crowds this is
the new refrain this is the new refrain
and unfortunately you know after 2020 we
wondered is this ending with 2020 no it
extended to the special elections in
2021 in January and Georgia it extended
to the midterm elections a couple weeks
ago in 2022 and it seems pretty clear
that this is going to be the narrative
that continues if we lost it was rigged
with all of the exact same statements
it's extraordinarily dangerous and so
far it hasn't flipped any races for them
imagine for a second that this story
about fraud and lawsuits and recounts
and barbecue sauce on ballots and all
this stuff imagine it actually flips an
election for them at some point
they will never stop using it if that's
the case that's why it's really
important that we ensure they aren't
actually able to steal an election by
claiming fraud and using these tactics
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself or
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with a vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below